welcome back to las vegas now if you're
looking for a unique gift to give this
holiday season we want to introduce you
to alex ross
a line of hand-painted wearable art
check it out
[Music]
i've been drawing kitties because i love
kitties
um i have two cats myself and i started
drawing those
probably about 25 years ago drawing is
my passion
so i have fun this is not like work to
me i always tell
gina that she's got the hard part
because i have the i have the easy part
i just sit and draw and my imagination
goes on and on
i fell in love with their artwork 15
years ago but it was last year and
last summer in august that i decided
that i wanted to
do a a vision that i'd had since i first
saw her
art her art just fills my heart with joy
and happiness and
i wanted other people to have that too
so
i called her last summer and
when she did the mural on my wall and
asked her if she would start drawing
specifically as a business for us for
aprons and
and purses and so that's what she
started doing and we focused all her
work on that
well we decided aprons because um
we wanted it big we wanted the artwork
work
big and um they show up great against
the white
and people are cooking more nowadays um
because they're staying in their homes
and so we thought it would be a really
fun way for
people to get into cooking our aprons
are
really well priced and they make great
gifts and
anybody who sees them loves them so
they're they're perfect for christmas
and the masks are of course because
everybody has to wear a mask now
and it's more fun to wear something that
is cute
over your face than something that's not
cute
we have masks for adults and kids we
started out with masks for adults but i
thought
i would see kids with masks on and they
you know and i thought
it would be much more fun for them if
they're going through having to wear
masks if they had
a kitty or a puppy on it because all
kids love kitties and puppies
i want people to enjoy
my art i want to put a smile on people's
faces
because when i have i mean before
we started this i made greeting cards
and
it always made people really happy you
send someone a card
you know with a little fluffy kitten or
a puppy on it
and it's going to make them smile we
have a website called
alex ross.world so go there
and you can see all of our aprons all of
our adult
and children's masks we also have
greeting cards
and wall art as well